[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
question d'actualité sur LCP une séance
un petit peu particulière ce mardi après
les émeutes urbaines de ces derniers
jours Emmanuel Macron reçoit en ce
moment même plus de 200 mères à l'Élysée
le chef de l'État estime que le retour
au calme devrait être arrivé le pic en
tout cas est passé mais il se montre
très prudent alors face à cette
actualité et bien la majorité ici à
l'Assemblée nationale s'affiche soudée
regardez cette image assez rare de la
première ministre venue saluer les
présidents des trois groupes de sa
majorité Renaissance le modem et horizon
c'était ce matin dans la cour d'honneur
de l'Assemblée Elisabeth borne qui s'est
ensuite rendu au à la réunion de
l'intergo pour présenter aux députés le
plan du gouvernement pour faire face aux
violences
urbaines nous faisons bloc et c'est
précieux à dire la première ministre qui
a présenté les quatre piliers de son
action va bien sûr revenir sur cette
actualité avec Elsa munding bah et
Stéphanie Despierre qui se trouve salle
des quatre colonnes nous retrouverons
également Marco pommier qui lui est dans
les tribunes pour le menu des questions
au gouvernement et puis nous reviendrons
pour d'honneur tout à l'heure pour
l'arrivée de la première ministre et des
membres du gouvernement ce sera juste
avant 15h alors pour leur on se retrouve
elles aiment un Gava qui allait et donc
celle des quatre colonnes alors Elsa il
y a eu beaucoup de tension ces derniers
jours qui s'est invité à l'Assemblée
nationale à quel après-midi faut-il
s'attendre ici oui mais souvenez-vous
Brigitte il y a une semaine jour pour
jour on apprenait un peu avant la séance
de questions gouvernement la mort de ce
jeune Anaël à Nanterre victime d'un tir
policier et bien une semaine a eu lieu
d'émeutes de débats de violences et
évidemment il en sera question dans
l'Assemblée nationale ici au cas de
colonnes les journalistes les députés ne
parlent que de ce thème aujourd'hui
évidemment oui Marco pommier va nous le
confirmer Marco vous êtes dans les
tribunes un thème unique aujourd'hui
pour cette séance de questions au
gouvernement
oui c'est ça Brigitte et c'était c'est
rare pour le souligner pratiquement
l'intégralité des questions gouvernement
seront consacrées aux événements de ces
derniers jours ces nuits d'émeutes après
le décès de Naël ce jeune de 17 ans tué
à Nanterre par un policier la
représentation nationale reviendra sur
le rétablissement de l'ordre public sur
la réponse pénale sur les conséquences
économiques pour les commerces et dans
ce contexte quelle réponse politique
comment soutenir comment protéger les
élus après l'attaque qui a visé la
famille de Vincent Jean Brun le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses la quasi-totalité des
présidents de groupe prendront la parole
c'est une séance au mouvementée qui
s’annonce à la première ministre Éric
Dupont-Moretti et Gérald Darmanin seront
en première ligne
merci Marco pommier je vous présente à
présent mes invités pour cette première
partie de question d'actualité violette
feelboutte bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député renaissance
du Nord et Hugo bernalissi bonjour
bonjour vous êtes également député du
Nord mais pour la France insoumise alors
l'exécutif cherche une réponse politique
après c'est émeutes urbaines le
président reçoit les mers à l'Elysée
hier il a reçu la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher la première
ministre elle s'est entretenue avec les
différents présidents de groupe à
Matignon et ce matin elle s'est exprimée
devant l'ensemble des groupes de sa
majorité Elsa vous êtes celle des quatre
colonnes quel est le message qui est
venu délivrer la première ministre
député et bien écoutez elle a voulu
délivrer un message d'unité nationale
vous l'avez dit tous les députés de la
majorité étaient invités et présent à
cette réunion de groupe il y avait
également les membres du gouvernement
concernés on peut penser à Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur Éric
Dupont-Moretti ministre de la Justice ou
encore Olivier première ministre de la
Ville un message d'unité nationale mais
aussi une violente charge politique
contre les insoumis selon la première
ministre les insoumis et leur refus de
condamner leur violence sont une preuve
supplémentaire à ses yeux que le parti
ne se positionne pas dans le champ
républicains voilà ce qu'a dit la
première ministre elle a rappelé au
député de la majorité les piliers de la
réponse du gouvernement la mobilisation
des forces de l'ordre la fermeté de la
réponse pénale la responsabilisation des
réseaux sociaux il appelle aussi à la
responsabilité parentale ça ce sont les
réponses à la crise la première ministre
a aussi dit qu'il fallait et bien tirer
les enseignements de cette crise à plus
long terme donc voilà donc les messages
qu'a voulu délivrer la première Mini ça
c'était devant sa majorité et puis on va
attendre et bien pendant la séance de
questions gouvernement les messages
qu'elle va délivrer à la représentation
nationale puisque vous l'avez dit
quasiment tous les présidents de groupe
vont lui poser des questions sur cette
crise
Hugo Bernal ici vont on a parlé de la
France insoumise ce matin la réunion de
l'intergroupe Renaissance modem horizon
pour dire que vous étiez hors du cadre
républicain hors du champ républicain
dans la réponse que vous avez apportée
lors de ces émeutes qu'est-ce que vous
avez à répondre je dirais que pour le
gouvernement finalement ces épisodes de
violence qu'on fait suite au meurtre du
jeune Naël sont une aubaine pour eux
pour se défausser de toute
responsabilité politique en les
entendant c'est comme si nous étions au
pouvoir depuis six ans comme si nous
dirigions le pays et que c'était nous
qui étions en charge de la police new
qui était en charge des quartiers
populaires dans ce pays nous qui est en
charge des etc enfin vous voulez dire
quoi que le gouvernement sort sur la
situation en profite en cynique et
qu'ils sont puisque tout ça permet
d'éclipser très très rapidement les
causes qu'on conduit aux événements qui
sont là nous sommes les seuls à avoir
vos connaissances on va revenir sur les
causes mais sur le cadre républicain
vous n'avez pas appelé au calme
expliquez-nous expliquez-nous pourquoi
nous sommes la seule organisation
politique à avoir proposé un plan
politique avec des mesures politiques
pour répondre politiquement à la crise
mais avant avant
si j'appelais au calme regardez
j'appelle au calme efficace
encore des problématiques est-ce qu'un a
pas eu hier ou avant-hier j'étais
moi-même devant la mairie de
mons-en-barœul quant à la brûlé aux
côtés des agents municipaux aux côtés
des habitants et des habitants la salle
aliend qui est en face que vous
connaissez probablement pas mais que moi
je fréquente pour y avoir des spectacles
culturels je trouve ça un bel équipement
oui je suis dégoûté qu'elle est brûlé
cette salle de spectacle oui je ne suis
pas d'accord avec le fait qu'on brûle
des mérites
parce que la cause du problème ce n'est
pas la France insoumise au cas où vous
n'auriez pas remarqué pas vous juste
vous mais vous le les macronistes etc si
c'était nous qui est déclenchions les
émeutes je vous dirais bah à côté on a
une responsabilité politique mais on a
rien de tout ça
parce que on vous accuse finalement de
surfer sur la situation d'abord la
première chose c'est que dire que la
France insoumise est hors du champ
républicain quand on regarde les paroles
de Monsieur bernaliste mais aussi les
paroles de l'ensemble de ces acolytes de
la France insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon
premier qui explique il y a quelques
jours que finalement pour les amitiés il
faut essayer d'épargner les
bibliothèques et les mairies mais entre
guillemets entre parenthèses pour le
reste les commissariats de police
qui est député de Lille comme moi on
connaît bien le territoire dit qu'il
était à mons-en-barœul au lendemain de
l'incendie de cette mairie mais sortir
du champ républicain c'est les maires
eux-mêmes qui le disent le maire de
mons-en-barœul n'a pas voulu de vous
Monsieur Bernard
incite à la haine utilise les réseaux
sociaux comme les députés de la France
insoumise pour attiser le feu pour
inciter des jeunes à une révolte dont
finalement ils ne se revendiquent même
des éléments puisque c'est grave aux
accusations
très républicaine comme tous les
présidents de groupe par la première
ministre à discuter et qui quitte la
Réunion donc voilà travailler ensemble à
l'unité nationale à trouver des
solutions pour les quartiers après des
années d'investissement public
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui se
doit se faire avec l'ensemble des élus
des territoires et surtout aux côtés des
mers parce que c'est les mers qui sont
au front aujourd'hui Hugo Bernal ici ces
jeunes qui se sont révoltés est-ce
qu'ils ont aussi profité un peu de la
situation du chaos est-ce que ce ne sont
pas des casseurs est-ce que vraiment
parce que quand on les a interrogés ceux
qui ont été interpellés il n'avaient pas
vraiment de bien avec Naël d'ailleurs je
voyais dans les retours des comparutions
immédiates qui en avait un qui était pas
du tout parti aux émeutes qui arrivait à
4-5 heures du matin et se balader dans
le quartier il y a eu un magasin qui
était ouvert il a pris ce qu'il y avait
dedans il s'est barré il s'est fait
attraper
les à qui est pour ça en fait dans le
pays qui est pour ça voudriez faire
croire qu'on est pour le pillage des
magasins
et ça c'est c'est quoi la suite vous
avez proposé la dissolution de la France
insoumise c'est ça on en est là bien
énervé monsieur
gouvernement oui effectivement
je vous mets encore c'est pas pareil je
vous mets en cause c'est pas pareil et
oui vous attisez la haine sur les
réseaux sociaux en faisant croire que
c'est nous qui sommes restables de la
situation mais à j'ai envie de vous dire
à la limite ça c'est le jeu politique
mais ce qui est dommage dans cette
histoire c'est que si vous pensez que
c'est nous qui sommes responsables de ça
alors vous n'allez rien régler du tout
parce que nous sommes responsables de
rien tout ça et vous ne voulez pas
traiter les codes j'ai vu le président
de la République dire il faut s'attaquer
aux causes j'espère qu'il va pas croiser
un miroir on va parler des causes avant
cela je voudrais qu'on retrouve qu'on
entend un peu la la parole de des
socialistes avec Roger Vico qui est
député socialiste et apparenté du Nord
et qui est au micro de Stéphanie
Despierre Roger vicoso week-end Olivier
fort le patron des socialistes a dit
qu'il était en profond désaccord avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'est-ce que vous
reprochez aux insoumis dans cette
période bah c'est l'appel à la justice
mais pas la peine au calme à quoi
d'autre voulez-vous qu'on appelle sinon
au calme dans cette période
particulièrement troublée et donc
effectivement je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement clair sur cette question
l'appel au calme et la première chose à
faire bien entendu
est-ce que ça peut être de nature c'est
divergences à remettre en cause
l'alliance ici avec la nups et donc avec
entre les socialistes et les insoumis je
n'en sais rien nous verrons comment les
choses évoluent dans les semaines et
dans les mois qui viennent mais de toute
évidence et je reprends les termes de
d'Olivier fort il y a un désaccord
profond et un désaccord profond c'est
quelque chose d'assez fondamental lui
effectivement on a une vision très
différente de la manière dont nous
souhaitons gérer cette période
imaginez les suites de cette période et
puis surtout gérer les médias de T et
dans l'immédiat je le répète bien
entendu on ne peut pas faire autre chose
que d'appeler au calme et de tenter de
le générer partout c'est possible on
parle beaucoup de la loi de 2017 la loi
à Cazeneuve qui a réglementé voire
assoupli pour certains la légitime
défense des policiers on entend ici les
insoumis réclamés son abrogation c'était
votre gouvernement socialiste est-ce que
désormais vous dites qu'il faut abroger
cette loi non c'est un autre point de
désaccord probablement je ne crois pas
que la loi de 2017 soit comme
l'expression a été employée à plusieurs
reprises par Jean-Luc Mélenchon a permis
de tuer une loi qui a été votée dans un
contexte très particulier après les
événements de 2015 au moment où des
policiers se faisaient attaquer et cette
loi elle n'autorise pas à tuer elle
précise les cas dans lesquels les
policiers peuvent et doivent utiliser
leur arme partant du principe que des
policiers sont amenés à utiliser leur
arme cette loi préciser les choses
cadrer les choses alors derrière
effectivement il y a une circulaire de
la direction de général de la police
nationale qui ouvrait un peu la porte à
aux policiers qui étaient laissés seuls
devant la possibilité le choix
d'utiliser l'arme ou pas et la
circulaire précisé même y compris même
si ce choix devait être contraire enfin
ou plutôt devait être considéré comme
mauvais a postériori donc c'est pas la
loi en tant que telle c'est
l'utilisation qui en a été faite et nous
appelons non pas une abrogation mais à
une révision plutôt pas une révision
plutôt une évaluation de la manière dont
cette loi a été appliquée car de toute
évidence elle a été mal appliquée
puisque l'utilisation des armes par la
police nationale on considéra blement
augmenté depuis 2017 mais je ne crois
pas que ce soit la loi elle-même qui
soit la cause de cela merci beaucoup
vous avez entendu Roger Vico il y a une
dissension assez forte finalement entre
les socialistes et la France insoumise
c'est peut-être le début de la fin de la
Nupe
vous aurez remarqué que nos votes sont
pas exactement les mêmes sur la loi de
rotation de programmation du ministère
des accords de fonds
la loi de 2007 par exemple sur la
légitime défense il y a un vrai
désaccord puisque vous voulez l'abroger
oui oui exactement après les frais sont
têtus en réalité les faits sont têtus
depuis cette modification et cette
introduction de l'article 435-1 de code
de la sécurité intérieure le nombre de
morts dans le cadre de refus de haute
tempérés a doublé et cet article ne
précise pas les conditions de la
légitime défense en général les
conditions d'usage de germes en général
laissez les conditions d'usage des armes
dans le cadre d'un refus d'obtempérer
donc j'ai un moment donné je veux bien
qu'on tourne autour du pot mais il y a
un problème alors il y a eu un
communiqué de presse officiel du Parti
socialiste qui visait à dire qu'il
fallait entamer une réflexion pour voir
si alors ils expliquent que c'est leur
application je comprends
seul donc
c'est compliqué de rompre avec le
quinquennat de François Hollande je
l'entends bien n'empêche que l'effet
sont têtus le problème politique
juridique et le problème politique nous
avons et en partie du à cet article 435
qui est rien et ceux qui ne veulent pas
le voir ne règleront pas les causes avec
cette loi 2017 sur la légitime défense
des policiers est-ce qu'elle va trop
loin est-ce qu'il faut la réviser en
tout cas aujourd'hui on voit Roger Vico
qui est aussi député dans ma ville de
Lille qui a des paroles sages et
rassembleuses je pense qu'on est à un
moment de violence urbaine qui ont
saccagé une grande partie des villes du
pays qui ont meurtri meurtri je le dis
des mères mais aussi des commerçants qui
sont encore aujourd'hui traumatisés par
la violence dont ils ont été témoins et
on est à un moment où on a besoin de
cette unité nationale donc on l'a ici
avec un élu du Parti socialiste avec
lequel je suis très souvent pas d'accord
y compris sur mon territoire mais en été
ensemble dans les parvis de sur les
parvis de nos mairies hier à midi moi
j'étais à Marcq-en-Baroeul aux côtés
d'un maire qui a été beaucoup touché
dans un quartier qui est le quartier de
la psychiatrie où on a un lycée
professionnel que j'ai visité ou
heureusement on a vu des jeunes très
responsables qui le lendemain après les
22 voitures brûlées faisaient du
nettoyage et de la remise en état de
leur outil de travail et d'apprentissage
auquel ils sont attachés ça montre aussi
qu'il y a plein de jeunes qui sont plein
d'espoir et envie de de d'être dans
cette unité nationale donc il faut pas
stigmatiser tous les jeunes et puis on
est lui était aux côtés du maire de
Lille on avait tous les partis
politiques là encore sauf la France
insoumise et donc moi je pense que là
on voit bien que on a un moment de
clivage politique extrêmement fort ceux
qui sont dans le champ des républicains
et qui savent se rassembler des
solutions à un problème dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville où tout
le monde sait que quel que soit les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés on a
mis beaucoup d'argent public beaucoup
d'intensité à l'action publique de
Jean-Louis Borloo juste avec des
résultats
quand on voit aujourd'hui des parents
qui sont démunis face à des enfants de
11 ans on a le plus jeune des
interpellés aujourd'hui qui a 11 ans
pendant ces violences policières ça
montre bien effectivement qu'on doit se
questionner et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
dit la première ministre quand elle
reçoit avec le président de la
République aujourd'hui tous les maires
qui ont été touchés par ces émeutes
c'est aussi pour leur dire un je suis à
l'écoute on va devoir travailler
rapidement pour un nouvel élan sur ces
quartiers parce que malgré tout l'argent
public et malgré l'effort sur la
médiation sociale la confiance dans les
centres sociaux et bien il y a encore
des efforts des jeunes effectivement qui
sont désœuvrés et qui en arrivent à te
de telsactions Hugo Bernal s'il y avait
des des députés la France insoumise
devant les mairies hier parce qu'il y
avait un appel pour soutenir Vincent
Jean Brun dont la famille a été attaquée
chez lui à la voiture bélier le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses sont allés devant leur
mairie aux côtés de leur mère là où ils
étaient disponibles et là où c'était
faisable et là où on n'est pas sur de la
récupération politique comme le fait
madame spielbout à l'instant parce que
avec son écharpe petit c'est juste notre
rôle monsieur le Président
macroniste est-ce que me faire insulter
par le maire macroniste de
mons-en-barœul qui était votre candidat
face à moi législatif vous condamnez
vous avez ainsi vous avez un condamnez
pas regardez l'état du centre de mon
papa c'est extrêmement grave ce que vous
êtes en train de dire c'est extrêmement
grave ce que vous êtes en train de dire
alors il y a eu une réponse Hugo
bernaliste de la première ministre
quatre piliers sur lesquels elle
s'appuie il y a d'abord un message de
fermeté avec 45000 policiers mobilisés
une réponse pénale aussi ferme la
responsabilité
responsabilisation des réseaux sociaux
et le rétablissement de l'autorité
parentale c'est la bonne réponse à court
terme en tout cas apporter ou pas les
causes le fait que des policiers tuent
des jeunes ça on en parle plus c'est
déjà plus le sujet c'est déjà plus le
sujet on est passé à autre chose
2017 vous y compris en tant que
journaliste parce que vous tournez
extrêmement vite la page pour les aider
eux à gérer la situation qu'il gère
extrêmement mal
il est lié aux causes de tout ça sur la
politique de la ville quand maintenant
tu nous dit on a des versets des
milliards alors quel ingratitude quel
indignité de ces jeunes gens et moins
jeunes qui qui ne votent pas pour
Emmanuel Macron alors qu'on leur met des
milliards des milliards d'euros et
souvent vous réclamez des moyens là ils
sont là regardez en Seine-Saint-Denis
bien qu'il y ait la politique de la
ville il y a pas eu des rapports
parlementaires pour montrer qu'il y
avait un sous-investissement de l'État
dans tous les domaines y compris dans le
regalien c'est pas moi qui le dit j'ai
compris la Cour des comptes
faire ce procès là et les jeunes de
là-bas et les moins jeunes devraient
fermer leur bouche on va écouter la
situation en Seine-Saint-Denis parce que
Stéphane peu qui lui est élu de cette
circonscription il est GDR communiste
Seine-Saint-Denis connaît très bien le
sujet et notamment le sujet des
banlieues il est à vos côtés justement
elles a mon Agava oui un peu un discours
qu'on entend beaucoup c'est que des
milliards il y en a qui ont été investis
et pourtant on voit le résultat
aujourd'hui alors est-ce qu'on a mis
assez d'argent est-ce qu'on a mis au bon
endroit d'abord c'est une idée fausse
l'Institut Montaigne par exemple a fait
la démonstration que pour un département
comme la Seine-Saint-Denis il est
beaucoup plus contributeur à la richesse
de la Nation par les différentes
fiscalités qu'ils ne reçoit d'aide de la
nation et il y a un faux semblant c'est
à dire les politiques de la ville les
politiques les différentes zones
notamment pour l'éducation ou pour la
police vous apporte quelques moyens
supplémentaires mais il ne compensent
jamais ce que les politiques de droit
commun donne en fait le rapport
parlementaire sur la Seine-Saint-Denis
de 2018 avait objectivé le fait que ces
quartiers populaires dans notre pays
avaient moins de République moins
d'enseignants moins de policiers moins
de magistrats moins de médecins et que
au contraire la promesse d'égalité
républicaine n'était pas au rendez-vous
vous savez moi ma conviction c'est que
il n'y a pas de territoire perdu de la
République mais il y a des territoires
que la République abandonne et en fait
c'est ça la réalité quel que soit les
les fake news qui peuvent être véhiculés
ici ou là alors le président de la
République reçoit des maires en ce
moment il semble considérer que le pic
est passé est-ce que vous sur le terrain
vous avez cette même analyse
sur le terrain depuis mercredi dernier à
en Seine-Saint-Denis oui depuis dimanche
dimanche soir hier lundi on peut
considérer que c'est beaucoup plus calme
c'est indéniable la question il faut que
ce soit durable je le l'espère nous y
travaillons tous responsable public en
discutant avec les uns les autres les
parents
les éducateurs les associations
je voudrais d'ailleurs en profiter pour
remercier vraiment l'engagement à la
fois des élus locaux et nationaux mais
aussi l'engagement de de tous les
responsables associatifs les parents
d'élèves qui n'ont pas ménagé leurs
efforts et continuent de s'activer pour
que le calme soit rétabli merci beaucoup
Stéphane peut effectivement on a vu des
parents des éducateurs parfois dans les
rues très tard pour essayer de faire
renier le calme violette pile bout il y
a eu un plan banlieue alors pas le plan
Borlo évidemment que Emmanuel Macron
avait balayé mais il y a eu un plan avec
des milliards qui ont été déversés et
pas que depuis Emmanuel Macron et
pourtant Stéphane peu en témoigner
effectivement il y a moins d'éducateurs
il y a moins de profs il y a il y a
moins de citoyensé dans le territoire
aussi d'une comment ça se fait moi
j'habite à Fives dans un des six
quartiers politiques de la ville sur 10
de la ville de Lille et effectivement il
y a encore plein de familles qui sont en
difficulté notamment les familles
monoparentales il y a le sujet du trafic
de drogue qui même aussi les combattu
avec des renforts de moyens de
renseignements internationaux restent un
vrai fléau pour l'ensemble de nos
sociétés et puis il y a le problème de
la parentalité et de l'éducation tous
ces sujets là elle méritent aujourd'hui
d'être réinterrogée on a fait plein de
choses et je ne vais pas vous aider
beaucoup de rénovations urbaines il y a
eu la rénovation urbaine il y a eu des
il y a eu beaucoup dans la lune contre
de chômage des jeunes dans ces quartiers
en 2017 à 5 points de moins aujourd'hui
c'est déjà mieux mais 18% de chômage
dans ces quartiers pour les jeunes c'est
toujours trop donc le problème c'est
l'autorité aujourd'hui c'est un défaut
je pense que baron doit se réinterroger
et c'est ce qu'on s'est dit ce matin
avec la première ministre lors de notre
réunion de groupe sur la famille le rôle
des parents le lien entre les parents et
l'école l'enseignement des valeurs
républicaines à l'école le travail
autour de l'école et le soutien moi j'y
tiens beaucoup au centre socio au MJC
qui font un travail de terrain quotidien
auprès de toutes les générations des
familles dans nos quartiers on a une
action publique en tout cas à
réinterroger parce que même si tout
n'est pas
rose on a de beaux résultats pour des
jeunes qui s'insèrent qui créent des
entreprises dans nos quartiers mais on a
aussi c'est toute une journée
là c'est 7000 personnes 8000 personnes
on a dit au total en France qui ont
réussi à piller et à casser le cœur de
nos quartiers de nos villes et donc ça
on peut pas l'accepter est-ce que vous
êtes meilleur d'accord sur ce constat-là
Hugo bernaliste c'est-à-dire un problème
d'autorité parentale non un problème
d'autorité parentale de rien du tout
des parents aujourd'hui qui n'arrivent
pas à tenir leurs enfants est-ce que
c'est la faute de l'école qui
n'accompagne pas aussi suffisamment les
enfants de leur parcours de citoyenneté
c'est pas de la faute de ceux qui
gouvernent ok répétez après
Emmanuel Macron non oui c'est pas de la
faute de ceux qui gouvernent évidemment
c'est la faute de la France insoumise
c'est la faute des parents c'est la
faute du manque d'éducateur c'est la
faute de je sais pas qui vont trouver la
semaine prochaine mais jamais de leur
faute et jamais de responsabilité donc
on est sur les parents les
responsabiliser ça pour vous ça n'aura
pas d'effet on parle des valeurs
républicaines moi je préfère les
principes aux valeurs les valeurs chacun
m'excusait derrière les principes ça
c'est dans le bloc de constitutionnalité
on apprend aux enfants libertés égalité
fraternité ils sortent de l'école
qu'est-ce qui constate la liberté un peu
moins qu'ailleurs l'égalité beaucoup
moins qu'ailleurs la fraternité ça
dépend des moments donc quand on
enseigne des principes il faut qu'il
s'incarnent dans le monde concret
palpable réel et quand vous avez des
milliards d'euros qui partent dans la
poche des actionnaires des grands
groupes protégés par la macronie même
incité à continuer de mettre de côté
parce que vous comprenez c'est eux qui
créent de l'emploi qui permet aux jeunes
de d'avoir cinq points de moins de
chômage chiffre que je comptais c'est
par ailleurs parce que si c'est pour les
en faire des livreurs deliveroo ou des
chauffeurs uber non merci sur le travail
précaire ça va quoi c'est encore une
fois à contentez-vous de cette précarité
au moins c'est mieux que rien c'est pas
possible
qui sont dans la rue la nuit que là il y
a pas quand même une petite
responsabilité des parents il y a une
responsabilité des parents de toute
façon en règle générale dans le fait de
s'occuper de ses enfants est-ce que vous
m'interrogez sur la responsabilité de de
monsieur Zemmour ou de Madame Morano
quand leurs enfants font des refus
d'obtempérer vous allez pas sur ce
terrain là pourquoi c'est pas le sujet
là aujourd'hui mais ce serait dommage
que ce soit le sujet non mais ça peut
être dans les qualités
dans quelles conditions dans quel
contexte évidemment bon donc vous voyez
bien que tout ça est un débat
extrêmement piégeux et alors pour faire
quoi la responsabilité des parents
qu'est-ce qu'on va changer on va changer
quoi dans le code pénal le fait de les
mettre en cause pénalement pour les
actes de leurs enfants
expliquer l'élément intentionnel le fait
de d'avoir un élément intentionnel quand
on ne prend pas soin de ses enfants
allez-y je vous écoute en tout cas moi
j'estime que il y a une responsabilité
des parents bien sûr et on sait qu'il y
a beaucoup de familles qui sont
désœuvrées quand un gamin de 11-12 ans
en bas de d'un immeuble du quartier de
Faubourg de Béthune à Lille gagne 80 100
150 euros pour être veilleurs pour la
drogue et qu'il ne va pas au collège je
sais pas si facile pour une maman de
pouvoir lui en faire entendre raison et
donc c'est à ça que servent
effectivement l'attention éducative les
éducateurs mais c'est quoi une faillite
alors de l'école de la République et
donc et aussi la lutte contre le trafic
de drogue donc tout ça ce sont des
politiques publiques et je le redis on
doit se réinterroger face à à ces jeunes
qui sont désœuvrés en revanche moi je
peux pas vous entendre tenir un discours
en permanence noir agressif haineux
parce que quand vous dites moi c'est les
principes mais en fait ce que vous
incarnez votre discours votre tonalité
même avec moi dans votre débat et bien
c'est un une tonalité qui qui ne donne
qui ne donne pas une un exemple pour
l'unité nationale aujourd'hui on a
besoin de vous en fait d'apaisement vous
êtes une on a des problèmes d'avoir de
la confiance pas d'opposer les uns aux
autres aujourd'hui dans les quartiers on
a beaucoup de parents qui nous demandent
de rétablir le calme parce que quand on
est dans une banlieue on n'a pas envie
de la violence et de la révolution comme
vous le dites on a envie du calme de
pouvoir aller travailler de pas avoir sa
voiture brûlée de pas voir son magasin
pillé et que son enfant puisse aller à
l'école d'avoir suffisamment de trésor
public d'avoir suffisamment de groupe
ici on est commissariats et bien moi je
considère aujourd'hui que la France
insoumise à une responsabilité forte et
que la violence de ses propos alors
qui justifie les violences qui
justifient les deux violents
pas d'accord de toute façon on va
écouter maintenant la parole
dans un petit instant mais on va écouter
la parole du rassemblement national par
la voie de Thomas ménager qui est député
RN du Loiret qui est à vos côtés
Stéphanie desperres Thomas ménager les
émeutes semble baisser en intensité
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement on attend que ça ne se
reproduise plus déjà à court terme que
ce retour progressif à l'ordre
républicain se poursuivent et on attend
surtout d'éviter de faire comme en 2005
c'est-à-dire de mettre la poussière sous
le CAPI et de ne pas régler les
problèmes profonds de notre société en
matière sécuritaire en matière sociale à
l'école on voit bien que les raisons de
cette situation chaotique sont multiples
c'est des raisons qu'on a sur lesquelles
on a alerté depuis des années il y a
bien entendu la nécessité déjà de faire
respecter les lois en place de peut-être
faire évoluer un certain nombre de
points législatif mais aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle surtout au gouvernement
c'est de faire respecter la loi parce
que tous ces jeunes aujourd'hui était
souvent bien connu des services de
police était parfois déjà avait déjà été
arrêté n'ont jamais été condamnés ils
savent il y avait des jeunes gens très
jeunes qui pour le coup étaient inconnus
et services de police oui il y a eu une
suite il y a un enchaînement mais on se
rend bien compte qu'on n'est pas venu là
tout doucement
c'est progressif ça fait des années
qu'on est dans un laxisme généralisé que
les lois ne sont plus respectées qu'ils
savent très bien que les forces de
l'ordre sont en sous-effectif c'était le
cas à Montargis sur mon territoire ils
étaient savaient très bien que
numériquement il pouvait tenir la ville
et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait pendant des
heures ils ont mis la ville à feu et à
sang des immeubles ont été détruits ont
été pillés et donc aujourd'hui on attend
que le garder sauts il en est capable
puisqu'il nous a habitué à un laxisme
généralisé d'envoyer des consignes très
claires et qu'on en arrête qu'on arrête
maintenant avec ce laxisme d'État et que
dès les premiers méfaits c'est ce que
nous nous souhaitons avec des peines
courtes il y ait maintenant que la
prison soit la règle et non l'exception
malheureusement avec tous ces pédales
alternatives aujourd'hui la prison est
trop souvent l'exception et non la règle
Hugo Bernal ici vous avez entendu pour
le rassemblement national il faut plus
de fermeté dans la réponse judiciaire à
apporter pour vous pour la France
insoumise pour vous pour la France
insoumise c'est quoi la réponse à
apporter aujourd'hui à ces jeunes
finalement qui font un peu ces sessions
la réponse elle est dans le traitement
des causes profondes qui font que des
jeunes gens se sentent légitimes à les
brûler une mairie une salle de spectacle
ou que sais-je encore n'importe quel
établissement public que nous mettons du
temps à construire qui au bénéfice de
toutes et de tous comment on en arrive
là parce que si on réfléchissait
réfléchit pas à ça et comprendre ça veut
pas dire excuser ça veut dire assez de
trouver des solutions concrètes pour y
répondre
il y a une partie de la réponse qui a
été donnée sur le fait que les services
publics doivent revenir dans ces
territoires abandonnés par la République
comme l'a dit Stéphane peu l'école soit
la même qu'ailleurs que les services
publics régaliens mais pas que soient
les mêmes qu'ailleurs qu'on est à
nouveau des antennes de la CAF des
antennes de Pôle emploi des antennes des
impôts etc de l'ensemble des services
publics et qu'on arrête de supprimer des
éducateurs de rue dans les clubs de
prévention parce que vous savez il y a
des mauvais procès qui sont faits au
club de prévention dans le département
du Nord c'est moins 5% tous les ans
parce que ce serait des repères pour les
drogués pour aider les jeunes désœuvrés
les voyous etc
de proximité parce que une des parties
de l'équation c'est la police et son
fonctionnement nous avons dit dans la
présidentielle et pas que en 2022 mais
aussi des gens en 2017 qu'il fallait
réformer en profondeur la police parce
qu'on peut pas passer écarter éviter le
problème comme ça quand vous avez une
multiplication par deux du nombre de
morts par armes à feu dans le cadre de
refuses de tempérer notamment des
passagers on va pas me faire croire que
les passagers étaient dangereux en soi
puisqu'ils ne sont pas au volant de
proximité c'est une réponse ou pas à
cette question pour rapprocher les
jeunes de la police dans les quartiers
mais ce qu'il faut un récipisser par
exemple les contrôles d'identité
qu'est-ce que vous connaissez une autre
programme visiblement relativement bien
puisque nous sommes pour instaurer
effectivement le récipissé pour les
contrôles d'unités parce qu'il y a trop
de contrôle officiels en tout cas vécu
comme tel par les jeunes dans les
quartiers c'est augmente le niveau de
tension ce qui est un problème sur le
trafic de stupéfiant un homme spielbou
je l'ai pas entendu moi sur la réforme
faite par Darmanin de la
départementalisation de la police qui va
avoir des lourds impacts sur la police
judiciaire qu'on manifesté devant les
tribunaux aux côtés des magistrats et
j'étais alors que tu es pour manifester
pour qu'ils aient les moyens de
démanteler les trafics pas le le jeûne
qui est en bas en train de faire le gai
ah ça ça fait un bâton dans la case on a
dit qu'on a démantelé un point de Deal
ça fait des beaux.com des beaux points
presse mais ça règle pas le problème moi
je suis pour régler les problèmes à la
racine et dans les problèmes à la racine
oui il y a le fonctionnement de la
police il y a un problème de racisme au
sein de la police nationale et c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est un rapport commandé
par le gouvernement auprès de monsieur
bergouiou qui en a fait état sur plus de
200 pages et je pense que les
macronistes globalement devraient sortir
de leur feuille d'éléments de langage et
un peu bosser les sujets regarder lire
regarder ce que font les sciences
humaines et sociales il y a plein de
choses à découvrir là dedans est-ce
qu'il faut réformer la police sortir
d'éléments de langage faire des études
merci de vos conseils monsieur Bernal
ici moi dans les commissariats quand je
vais dans un commissariat c'est pour
aller rencontrer ces femmes et ces
hommes qui sont policiers qui risquent
leur vie en particulier dans les
derniers jours de violence urbaines avec
beaucoup de courage et de dignité parce
qu'ils savent qu'en face d'eux ils ont
des jeunes des jeunes très jeunes et
qu'il faut faire très attention avec des
circonstances très difficiles pour
intervenir la nuit avec des éléments
lumineux de la fumée qui empêche une
intervention simple et organisée et puis
je ne fais pas comme les députés de la
France insoumise eux quand ils veulent
viennent dans un commissariat ils vont
dans les cellules de garde à vue non pas
pour comme de vrai le faire un député
vérifier les conditions de détention et
de privation de liberté mais bien pour
échanger pour attiser on le sait quand
ils viennent c'est le message de
défiance envers la police qu'il porte
les policiers le savent moi aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de leur dire qu'on est avec
eux les Français sont avec eux parce que
ils protègent nos quartiers il protège
de l'un des délinquance oui il y a des
erreurs il y a eu transparence complète
sur la mort de Naël et le prévenu est
aujourd'hui mis en examen en rétention
homicide volontaire et il y aura toute
transparence sur cette situation mais
jeter l'eau propre sur l'ensemble de nos
forces de l'ordre comme le fait la
France on a bien compris de vision
totalement opposées du du de la police
aujourd'hui sur sur ce plateau merci à
tous les deux en tout cas d'être venu
débattre assez franchement ici dans
question d'actualité on va à présent
passer au focus dans cette émission
[Musique]
et revenons sur le projet de loi justice
qui est en débat actuellement dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale il
prévoit des moyens supplémentaires
jusqu'à 11 milliards en 2027 l'embauche
de 10000 personnes supplémentaires dont
1500 magistrats et alors on va retrouver
Stéphanie Despierres aux côtés de Jean
tardier qui est lui rapporteur général
du projet de loi député renaissance du
Tarn Jean terrier à quoi va servir cet
argent supplémentaire sur la justice
alors écoutez cette loi de programmation
et d'orientation du ministère de la
Justice les 20% d'augmentation du budget
et qui portera à plus de 54%
d'augmentation du budget de la justice
depuis 2017 va servir principalement à
embaucher 10 000 personnels de justice
c'est 1500 greffiers 1500 magistrats
c'est la création d'attachés de justice
qui vont venir renforcer l'équipe autour
du magistrat mais c'est aussi des
revalorisations pour ces personnels de
justice on a parlé des 1000 euros pour
les magistrats il va y avoir des
discussions qui vont s'ouvrir à
l'automne avec les greffiers c'est
également les les surveillants
pénitentiaires qui vont bénéficier de
ces revalorisations de de rémunération
donc l'objectif il est clairement
affiché c'est celui de réduire de moitié
les délais de jugement tant aussi villes
qu'en pénal de faire un changement
numérique important au niveau des
services du service public de la justice
voilà pour l'essentiel ce à quoi va
servir ces augmentations de budget qui
sont encore une fois historiques les
républicains
je crois qu'on
a un plan 15000 places qui est
excessivement ambitieux qui a pris un
peu de retard mais qui devrait arriver
d'ici à 2027 à la réalisation de ces
15000 places attendues moi ce que
j'aurais envie de dire aux républicains
aujourd'hui c'est et des nous d'abord à
permettre la réalisation de ces 15000
places de prison on sait qu'il y a parmi
les opposants parfois des opposants de
la famille politique des républicains
qui font des blocages sur le terrain
parce que on a beau appeler à faire des
prisons au fond quand on est sur le
terrain la problématique est un peu
différente donc j'aurais envie de dire à
Monsieur Ciotti qui réclame plus de
prison et des nous d'abord avec vos
alliés sur les territoires à réaliser ce
plan 15000 places et puis après on verra
la gauche elle s'inquiète de mesure
il y a disposition dans la loi qui
permettra d'activer la surveillance par
téléphone portable à distance moi je
crois qu'il faut pas il faut éviter les
fantasmes autour de ces de ces procédés
qui sont en réalité que des procédés de
mise à jour pour permettre à nos
enquêteurs tout simplement de faire face
à des améliorations technologiques
aujourd'hui il y a pas de risque pour
les libertés publiques non il y a aucun
risque pour les libertés publiques parce
que les procédés qu'on met en place
existent déjà quand on savait on pose
une balise sous une voiture on permet
déjà la géolocalisation d'une voiture là
aujourd'hui on a des moyens modernes des
téléphones notamment qui vont nous
permettre d'actionner ces moyens
évidemment pour permettre à nos
enquêteurs d'avoir un travail qui est
plus efficace et qui est évidemment plus
en sécurité pour eux
merci à vous
si vous nous rejoignez sur LCP sachez
que nous sommes à moins d'une demi-heure
maintenant la séance de questions au
gouvernement que vous allez pouvoir
suivre en direct et en intégralité sur
LCP vous le voyez la garde républicaine
est déjà installée derrière moi ils ont
présenté leurs armes la revue des trous
bien d'avoir lieu les tambours sont à
leurs pieds et tout à l'heure ils
joueront pour la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ce sera juste
avant 15h quand elle arrivera pour
présider cette séance deux questions au
gouvernement à suivre sur LCP alors avec
moi dans cette émission vous retrouverez
bien sûr Elsa mon ningava et Stéphanie
Despierre qui se trouve celle des quatre
colonnes nous retrouvons également Marco
pommier qui lui est déjà dans les
tribunes de l'hémicycle pour le menu des
questions au gouvernement et puis vous
vivrez l'arrivée en direct de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne et de
tous les membres du gouvernement ce sera
par l'entrée principale du palais
Bourbon c'est-à-dire la cour d'honneur
de l'Assemblée on trouve tout de suite
Marco justement Marco pommier dans les
tribunes de l'hémicycle Marco un thème
unique aujourd'hui pour cette séance de
questions au gouvernement
oui brigitte c'est assez rare pour le
souligner pratiquement l'intégralité des
questions au Gouvernement seront
consacrés aux événements de ces derniers
jours 9 des 10 présidents de groupe
prendront la parole tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycles la représentation nationale
reviendra sur ses nuits d'émeutes après
le décès de Naël ce jeune de 17 ans tué
mardi dernier à Nanterre par un policier
au moins trois questions sur la réponse
pénale face aux violences urbaines et
puis dans ce contexte quelle réponse
politique quelle reconstruction possible
le groupe lyaute réclamera le retour du
plan Borlo sur les banlieues ce plan qui
avait été enterré par Emmanuel Macron en
2018 la gauche elle interpellera le
gouvernement sur une réforme de
l'institution policière
merci Marco et je vous présente à
présent mes invités pour cette seconde
partie de questions d'actualité Ludovic
Mendes bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député renaissance de la
Moselle et Julien dive bonjour bienvenue
à vous vous êtes député les républicains
de l'Aisne alors on va tout de suite
partir pour ces questions au
gouvernement avec Olivier marlex le
président du groupe les républicains qui
comptent comme quasiment l'ensemble des
présidents de groupe interpellés la
première ministre cet après-midi dans
l'hémistique sur les réponses pénales il
pose avant tout sa question à Elsa mon
Agava oui pour vous la réponse c'est la
réponse pénale qui compte aujourd'hui
qu'allez-vous demander la première
ministre l'urgence pour finir d'endiguer
cette crise et puis parce que ce qui
s'est passé très grave pour pour notre
pays c'est évidemment une réponse pénale
ferme et rapide ça veut dire ça veut
dire que je demanderai moi la première
ministre de nous donner des comptes
qu'on est régulièrement semaine après
semaine département par département le
nombre de procédures qui ont été engagés
de personnes déférées devant la justice
et de condamnation qui ont été prononcés
la justice elle juge au nom du peuple
français je pense que les Français sont
en droit de savoir quels seront les
suites pénales c'est aussi ce qu'on doit
aux forces de l'ordre après c'est très
dur moment qu'à traverser notre notre
pays
vous débattez justement en ce moment
d'un projet de loi sur la justice vous
les républicains vous voulez par exemple
l'instauration de peine plancher oui
bien sûr enfin il y aurait tant de
choses à dire évidemment je crois qu'il
va falloir remettre beaucoup de choses à
plat le gouvernement ne pourra plus se
cacher comme ils le faisait les plaines
planchers elles existaient à ce Nicolas
Sarkozy la suppression des allocations
familiales pour les parents
d'enfants délinquants elles existent une
école à Sarkozy le gouvernement a refusé
par deux fois ce gouvernement ce
président de la République ont refusé
par deux fois de le rétablir donc
évidemment on aura cette discussion mais
on est encore dans cette crise parce que
je demande c'est que la justice fasse
son travail et le fasse rapidement et
notamment le gouvernement a bien se
donner des défis en 100 jours moi je
leur demanderai qu'en 100 jours toutes
les affaires soient jugées ce qui n'est
pas impossible il tout simplement que le
gouvernement mobilise tout ce qui peut
mobiliser de magistrats notamment vous
savez des magistrats honoraires des
magistrats en mission temporaire qui
doivent être mobilisés pour que la
justice rende des décisions très
rapidement dans cette affaire et je veux
qu'on aille chercher la responsabilité
des parents notre code pénal prévoit
aujourd'hui c'est un article qui est
l'article
l227-17 c'est un peu technique mais il
faut que les Français sachent que c'est
la loi
qu'on peut aller chercher la
responsabilité des parents la
responsabilité pénale lorsqu'il y a un
manquement éducatif flagrant et on
laisse pas un gamin de 14 ans de 15 ans
tout seul à deux heures ou 3 heures du
matin dans une ville où il y a des
émeutes urbaines c'est la loi et le
gouvernement doit appliquer cette loi
merci beaucoup Olivier marnech président
du groupe les républicains insistait
donc sur la réponse pénale une question
à présent de la majorité toujours sur la
réponse pénale celle de Sacha Houlier
elle va interpeller tout à l'heure le
gouvernement il est député renaissance
de la Vienne et il est président de la
commission des lois il est à votre micro
Stéphanie Despierres Sacha pour
commencer calez-vous demander au
gouvernement d'abord j'ai posé la
question on garde des sceaux de ce qui a
été fait parce que là il y a une réponse
de est extrêmement forte par les
parquets pour avoir des réquisitoires
très importants contre les émeutiers par
les magistrats qui ont prononcé des
peines fermes ensuite à l'égard des
parents puisqu'on attendait parents qui
le garde leur fils et puis enfin pour le
contrôle des réseaux sociaux puisque
c'est les trois axes sur lesquels le
gouvernement a travaillé donc on veut
connaître aujourd'hui les résultats qui
ont permis et bien d'avoir les nuits
plus calmes qu'on a connu ces derniers
jours Olivier Marleix réclame le retour
des peines plancher qui existaient sous
Nicolas Sarkozy qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez pas que ce n'est pas un sorcier
les autres et supprimé c'est parce
qu'elles étaient profondément
inefficaces personne va payer un magasin
ou casser la figure des policiers avec
un code pénal sous le bras ça n'existe
pas donc chacun fait son petit marché
électoral maintenant nous on préfère
rétablir l'ordre restaurer l'autorité de
l'État c'est ce qu'on nous a demandé
45000 policiers ont été déployés sur le
terrain ils ont réussi à amener le calme
ce qui n'était pas gagné compte tenu de
la nature des émeutes avec des peines
qui ont été prononcées qui sont
extrêmement fortes et si les
républicains veulent vraiment faire
œuvres utiles on peut les inviter à
voter la loi sur la justice qui est en
ce moment en cours d'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale
alors Julien Dive vous avez entendu
Sacha oulier qui critique finalement
votre proposition de rétablissement des
peines plancher est-ce que c'est
véritablement la solution là dans le cas
qui nous occupe le problème c'est que
quelqu'un comme ça chez Olivier faisait
partie de ceux qui soutenaient dans le
précédent quinquennat celui de François
Hollande ceux qui ont contribué au
laxisme du judiciaire que l'on connaît
je rappelle qu'à l'époque nous avions
sous Nicolas Sarkozy fait adopter un
certain nombre de mesures qui permettait
justement au travers des pennes
planchers mais il y avait d'autres
mesures comme notamment touché au
portefeuille des familles lorsqu’un
délinquant enfant mineur comité des
actes comme ceux qu'on a pu connaître ce
week-end et ça a été retiré
de revenir sur cette question il y a en
tout cas porter la réflexion dessus et
c'est sous François Hollande que cette
dispositif ce dispositif a été supprimé
cette loi nous avions tenté de la
déposer la présenter en 2019 puis en
2021 et c'est le gouvernement actuel
qu'il avait rejeté donc voilà chacun
peut revenir et c'est tant mieux sur ses
positions dans la question je pense par
exemple
vous entendez poser la question de la
réponse c'est un bouquet de réponse
qu'il faut avoir un bouquet de réponse à
la fois une réponse pénale ça vient
d'être évoqué et il y a le texte sur les
justices qui est en débat et nous nous
voulons de la fermeté nous voulons
davantage de mesures parce qu'en fait je
crois que c'est le délitement aussi de
la réponse judiciaire qui a fait que
nous en sommes là avec un défaut
d'autorité une réponse politique
évidemment et là il appartiendra au
gouvernement de porter cette réponse
politique et une troisième réponse c'est
la réponse républicaine qui appartient
finalement à toute à toutes les citoyens
à tous les citoyens c'est celle qui
évoquait Vincent Jean Brun ce week-end
nous avons tous une part de République
je crois qu'il y avait juste à ce
moment-là dans la famille a été attaquée
chez lui à la voiture bélier Ludovic
Mendes vous avez entendu Olivier marlex
le président du groupe les républicains
ils demandent plus de fermeté il veut un
suivi dans les les condamnations
finalement de ces de ces jeunes est-ce
que en 100 jours vous pouvez apporter
cette réponse j'ai surtout la sensation
que Monsieur Alex n'a pas écouté ce qui
a été dit toute la fin de semaine
dernière parce que c'est exactement ce
qui a été dit par le Président de la
République le ministre de l'Intérieur le
ministre de la Justice fermeté réponse
pénale et pas que au final civile aussi
parce que on parle de faire payer les
familles mais l'arrêter c'est que le
Code civil prévoit déjà que les familles
du moins les enfants qui ont cassé les
responsabilités ce sont les parents on
peut aller chercher l'argent chez les
parents après ils sont pas tous en
capacité de payer non plus il y a une
réalité à prendre en considération
des allocations familiales par exemple
pour les parents je vois pas quel est
l'intérêt de la République j'ai le droit
d'être de pas toujours être d'accord de
noter le président de la République n'a
pas dit qu'il allait le faire il a dit
qu'il fallait qu'on réfléchisse à
plusieurs choses après je le vois j'ai
le droit d'être la majorité de dire que
je suis pas un accidentellement parce
que en l'état je ne vois pas à quoi ça
va servir casser quelque chose dire à
quelqu'un vous a retirez les allocs
qu'est-ce que ça va changer le plus à
part les paupériser et les enfoncer dans
un système où ils sont ils sont
persuadés d'être victimes d'un système
national alors que c'est totalement faux
justement il faut démonter cette réponse
que vous apportez vous la majorité la
première ministre c'est de
responsabiliser les parents c'est de
dire que voilà des des gamins qui ont 11
12 13 ans ils doivent pas être dans la
rue en pleine nuit et c'est peut-être ça
qui a porté ses fruits dans la la fin
des des émeutes
ce weekend avec des mamans qui elle-même
faisaient un cordon de sécurité devant
l'école et qui nous disait mais ces
gamins-là ce ne sont pas les nôtres
parce qu'ils ne sont même pas du
quartier il y a aussi une réalité c'est
de regarder dans le détail ce qui s'est
passé territoire par territoire parce
que la solution n'est pas la même
territoire par territoire il faut
prendre en considération les différents
catégories de famille les difficultés de
ces familles et peut-être qu'au lieu de
proposer de retirer des allocations de
créer des maisons de la parentalité sur
ces territoires pour accompagner ses
parents qui sont dépassés parfois par
leur jeunesse et qui sont
malheureusement ça existe en réalité ça
existe dans les zones
urbaines prioritaires ça existe partout
sauf que ce débat on ne le pose jamais
on a des parents qui sont parfois
dépassés moi je le vois en
circonscription on l'a vécu pendant les
gilets jaunes une maman en zone rurale
qui nous expliquait dépassée par ces
trois enfants qu'elle est levée seul il
fallait comprendre aussi ce qu'elle nous
disait je ne lui ai pas jeter la pierre
on doit pas jeter la pierre toujours aux
parents ils sont parfois dépassés il
faut l'assumer il faut l'accepter mais
il faut pouvoir les aider et on les aide
pas en leur retirant des allocations
familiales on les aide peut-être par des
maisons de la parentalité on les aide
par des devoirs fait à l'école on les
aide pas l'accompagnement du système
scolaire
c'est quand même une réponse de fermeté
aujourd'hui avec des policiers mobilisés
la responsabilisation des parents le la
réponse judiciaire c'est la bonne
réponse à apporter pour vous il faut un
retour à l'autorité de l'État donc c'est
une réponse qu'on doit apporter tout de
suite maintenant dans l'urgence et pour
l'avenir avoir une réponse et d'autorité
et une réponse sociale en même temps
aussi un retour de l'autorité parentale
parce qu'à un moment donné lorsque vous
êtes parents vous avez des droits et
aussi des devoirs et dans ces devoirs
c'est d'éduquer vos enfants et lorsque
vous vous faites des faux à vos propres
devoirs et normal aussi qu'à un moment
donné l'état vous demande des comptes la
question des aides et je pense qu'elle
se poser réellement contrairement à mon
collègue moi je crois que c'est un sujet
qui mérite d'être posé sur la table il y
a plein de solutions il y a pas une
solution c'est pas la politique des
bisounours dans tous les cas qui va
permettre de résoudre le problème et la
crise qu'on en est en train de dire que
en étage je veux savoir à quoi ça sert
c'est tout ce que je dis il y a eu ce
plan Borlo qui a été avorté est-ce que
pour vous il faudrait revenir sur ce
plan Borlo il faudrait rétablir redonner
plus de moyens pour la rénovation
urbaine alors on sait déjà que des
milliards et des milliards ont été
déversés dans les banlieues il y a déjà
eu des tas de milliards qui ont été
investis il y a une politique qui a été
menée notamment sur les dédoublements
des classes donc il y a réellement des
moyens qui sont mis vous faites le tour
des
qpv des ZUP moi j'ai une ZUP il y a des
investissements qui sont menés si c'est
pas par l'État c'est par les
collectivités les régions les
départements chacun prend sa part de
responsabilités les investissements ont
été faits je crois qu'en réalité il faut
certainement pas couper les vivres et au
contraire continuer de maintenir ses
politiques mais c'est pas avec des
milliards supplémentaires des coups de
milliards qu'on va résoudre finalement
tous ces problèmes il faut maintenir une
politique évidemment de la ville sans
doute dans le plan de Borlo il y a un
certain nombre de dispositions qui sont
à reprendre mais en même temps faut pas
opposer ville et campagnes opposer vivre
et ruralités il faut pas se dire que la
réponse du coup elle doit être quoi de
sur les banlieues et l'autre coup sur la
réalité il faut que ce soit juste un bon
équilibre parce que vous avez la moitié
des Français qui vivent en ville et la
moitié des Français qui vivent en
réalité ça ne doit pas se faire
détriment de l'un ou de l'autre donc
c'est une vraie politique d'ensemble je
crois que Borlo était un des fervent
défenseur de la mixité sociale c'est
aussi un des moyens de parvenir
justement à peut-être faire corps un peu
plus dans notre République c'est les
questions de la mobilité vous avez des
des gens qui vivent dans des quartiers
et qui restent dans les quartiers qui
consomment dans les quartiers qui se
forment dans les quartiers et qui
peut-être parfois ne travaillent pas
dans le travail pas tout simplement donc
faut aussi assurer la mobilité partout
c'est l'échec du président de la
République d'avoir balancé un peu ce
plan Bordeaux de ne pas non on a
appliqué 80 % du plan Bordeaux au mandat
précédent donc on peut pas dire qu'on ne
l'a pas fait puisque on l'a pas appelé
plan Borlo mais on l'a mis 80 % de ce
qui était proposé on l'a créé en réduire
en politique publique la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on faudrait que si
certaines communes acceptent de
respecter la loi et c'est rue par
exemple celui d'arrêter et rénovation
urbaine ou on a des communes qui
n'atteignent pas 25% de logements
sociaux et ça sert à beaucoup de
Français il faut faire en sorte qu'on
n'est pas des communes non plus on a
plus de 1 logements sur deux qui soit
des logements sociaux parce qu'on crée
du communitarisme aussi sur ces
territoires là il faut un plan nation un
plan nation qui répond à des communes
qui perdent des habitants et d'autres où
il y en a trop des territoires où on n'a
pas assez de logement et des territoires
on a des logements vite est disponibles
cette réalité territoriale nous la
connaissons il faut réaménager moi je
fais partisan de ceux qui disent qu'il
faut détruire certaines communes à
moitié comme on l'a fait à Montréal par
exemple le Canada l'a fait ça fonctionne
pour recréer de la société sociale et
sans qu'on n'a pas cette mixité qu'on a
pas cette capacité de sortir les gens de
leur territoire qui sont en ruralité ou
en zone j'allais dire
urbaine plus pauvérisée on ne trouvera
pas de réponse parce que c'est justement
ce lien avec le reste de la nation qui
fait qu'on se sent tous j'allais dire
dans un système d'appartenance
collective à la République à la nation
française et certaines personnes
aujourd'hui en réalité comme dans ces
zones paupérisées ce sont totalement
exclus et assignés à résidence on va à
présent prendre une autre question celle
de Emeline cabidi qui est député
communiste Gauche démocrate et
républicaine de la Réunion qui compte
interpeller le gouvernement sur la
cagnotte ouverte pour la famille du
policier qui a tué Nael oui plus d'un
million 400.000 euros recueillis madame
kerbidy est-ce que cette cagnotte on
vous en parle et ce qu'elle vous choque
et que voulez-vous demander au
gouvernement alors cette cagnotte elle
est choquante elle est choquante à plus
d'un titre parce que on a des centaines
de milliers d'euros qui sont récoltés
pour un policier qui a tué un jeune et
donc il y a eu un avec la cagnotte de
Christophe detargé et à l'époque le
gouvernement s'était prononcé madame
borne était un gilet jaune qui avait été
filmé en train d'attaquer des policiers
tout à fait et le policier n'était pas
mort mais il avait été blessé
effectivement et Madame borne qu'à
l'époque était ministre des Transports
c'était indigné de cette cagnotte et
très vite la justice avait été saisie et
la justice avait annulé cette cagnotte
et aujourd'hui la seule réponse du
gouvernement c'est de nous dire que ça
n'apaise pas la situation c'est
effectivement c'est peu de le dire ça
n'apaise pas la situation mais ce que
l'on demande au gouvernement c'est de
prendre position et de dire clairement
que cette cagnotte elle est immorale que
cette cagnotte elle est illégale et que
c'est un trouble à l'ordre public et
qu'elle doit être annulée on vous en
parle beaucoup de cette cagnotte elle
choque les gens que vous rend que vous
rencontrez le pire avec cette cagnotte
c'est que elle met à Nupe une fracture
au sein de la société on a ceux qui
trouvent que la cagnotte est choquante
et on a ceux qui abondent la cagnotte et
je pense qu'effectivement dans la
société et dans le moment de crise que
nous traversons si l'on veut appelé à
l'apaisement il ne faut pas seulement
des mots il faut aussi des actes et
cette cagnotte elle doit cesser merci
beaucoup Emeline carillon le rappelle en
cette cagnotte elle a été lancée par des
politiques d'extrême droite et elle
dépasse le million d'euros Ludovic
Mendes est-ce que c'est choquant est-ce
qu'il faut la supprimer cette cagnotte
c'est la liberté on en démocratie ça a
été monté on n'est pas sur des personnes
terroristes non plus et pour la famille
de la gente police je comprends que ça
puis choquer entre la cagnotte faite
pour la famille de Naël et
effectivement ça s'entend je rappelle
que l'État va prendre 60% de d'impôts
sur cette cagnotte aussi c'est une
réalité parce que ce sont des dons fait
par des personnes extérieures à la
famille c'est un débat qui a été posé
par les politiques de gauche mais ils se
rendent pas compte que parfois ils
envoient eux-mêmes ces personnes sur
cette cagnotte parce qu'il bouscule la
police en permanence quand ils vont dans
les manifestations interdites et qui
font en sorte qu'il y a du caillassage
permanent quand ils appellent à la
justice mais pas au calme dans notre
pays illégitime en fait ce genre de
cagnotte et les personnes qui vont vers
l'extrême droite et on doit être quand
on demande à être responsable qu'il le
soit déjà eux-mêmes et qu'ils arrêtent
toutes ces actions contre la police et à
force de fait partout la police tue il y
a des personnes qui envoient aussi des
messages pour dire que ils soutiennent
la police via cette cagnotte là parce
que parfois il y a des agents de police
qui font des erreurs et qui commettent
des bavures mais c'est pas l'ensemble de
la police que l'on retrouve
effectivement par Jean Messi a de
l'extrême droite Julien dips c'est au
fond un soutien aux forces de police
cette cagnotte qui atteint un million
446000 alors qu'il est sur la forme
c'est pas le moi c'est pas le c'est pas
la forme qui m'intéresse la liberté de
chacun de donner contribuer et libre et
appartient à chacune et chacun qui est
une véritable un véritable soutien Forza
dans comtesse qu'on vient de vivre avec
justement ces émeutes avec des policiers
qui ont été victimes et je tiens à
rappeler quand même que la République a
quand même failli vaciller c'était ça en
200000 personnes dans la rue qui ont mis
le bazar qui ont mis plus que le bazar
et c'est grâce au courage des policiers
des gendarmes des pompiers que la
République a pu tenir maintenant il
faudrait qu'il y ait une réponse
maintenant sur la cagnotte je vais vous
dire ce qui est malaisant ce qui est
malsain ce qui est presque dégueulasse
et passer moins l'expression parce
qu'elle est pas belle c'est la
récupération politicienne qui est faite
d'un côté par l'extrême droite et de
l'autre côté par l'extrême gauche parce
qu'en fait en faisant ça en continuant
d'opposer les uns aux autres les gens
aux forces de l'ordre les les banlieues
aux gens des campagnes ou des villes on
ne contribue qu'à une chose à fracturer
davantage le pays et à créer ce climat
délétère que nous rejetons tous on va
retrouver à présent Bertrand pencher qui
est président du groupe liotte à
l'assemblée qui va interpeller la
première ministre tout à l'heure il est
à votre micro Stéphanie Despierres
Bertrand pencher vous voulez
l'application du plan borload 2018 qui
est resté écrit mais sans application
qu'est-ce qu'il faut appliquer qui était
dans ce plan d'abord j'étais frappé par
ce rapport c'est un rapport qui est
prophétique c'est à dire Jean-Louis
Borloo expliquait en 2017 que il fallait
rétablir l'ordre
dans les dans les banlieues et dans les
villes dans les villes en difficulté et
la cohésion sociale et qu'il fallait
traiter le mal par la racine
c'est-à-dire par des tas de mesure
éducatifs politiques de la ville des
murs sociales d'intégration des emplois
aidés en expliquant que on ne pourra pas
demain reconstruire quoi que ce soit si
la promesse de fraternité n'est pas
n'est pas une promesse inscrite dans les
objectifs de la République vous estimez
qu'Emmanuel Macron a complètement raté
ce rendez-vous avec les banlieues dont
il a eu beaucoup parlé pendant sa
campagne de 2017
ce rapport Borlo il a été rédigé par
plus de 200 élus locaux de grandes enfin
des des propositions de très grande
qualité de bon sens le plus élémentaire
on l'a jeté aux orties en traitant de
Bordeaux de mal blanc enfin tout ça
n'avait aucun sens et finalement au lieu
de concentrer des moyens sur les
territoires oubliés de la République il
y a les territoires urbains il y a aussi
les territoires ruraux et bien cinq ans
à peine 5 ans après la crise des gilets
jaunes ou en Émile feu au pays et bien
il y a la crise il y a la crise des
banlieues je condamne évidemment toute
enfin toute ces violences et tous les
acteurs de ces violences évidemment
c'est pas un sujet mais en même temps il
faut traiter il faut traiter les sujets
sur le fond et le mal par la racine
merci et puis je vous laisse rejoindre
l'hémicycle pour poser votre question au
gouvernement merci Ludovic Mendes
Emmanuel Macron avait promis en 2017 la
fin de la signation à résidence ça par
évidemment à tous ces jeunes de banlieue
ou qui ont l'impression que leurs
parents ne s'en sortent pas est-ce que
finalement ça c'est un peu votre échec
non parce que je crois qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites
alors l'état fait beaucoup de choses
après il faut aussi qu'on travaille avec
les collectivités sur le sur le terrain
et elles font le travail aussi je veux
dire je connais aucun élu local que
faire en sorte que ça puisse pourrir sur
son territoire mais ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne à l'école ça fonctionne ça
mobilité ça fonctionne sur l'emploi les
chiffres démontrent il est reparti je
pense que ça fonctionne à titre
personnel je le vois sur certains
quartiers autour de autour de Metz on le
voit dans les chiffres mais ça suffit
pas encore il y a un vrai travail à
faire aussi sur la lutte contre les
discriminations il y a un travail qui a
fait aussi contre la communauté et il y
a un véritable effort à faire sur la
redynamisation de ces territoires et de
leur redonner vie je sais pas ce qu'il y
a des zones franches qu'on crée de
l'emploi l'emploi n'est pas toujours
dépendant de ces zones franches au
contraire sont des personnes qui en sont
éloignées mais il faut qu'on puisse
accompagner un peu mieux si le milieu
associatif qu'on a peut-être un peu
délaissé toutes ces années parce qu'on a
mis des moyens ailleurs et je crois que
l'entreprise comme le pouvoir public ont
de quoi redonner des dynamiques sur ces
territoires là effectivement il faut
mettre les moyens sur le milieu
associatif sur les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent em ces jeunes
devant-lieu il y a pas de fatalité au
déterminisme social c'est-à-dire qu'en
gros chacun ou qu'ils vivent de pouvoir
évoluer dans la société trouver sa place
en fonction de ses de ses désirs et en
fonction du moment où trouve une place
mais ça passe par un bouquet de solution
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure il y a
la réponse pénale et évidemment elle
fait partie de ce bouquet de réponse
parce qu'on doit pouvoir établir
l'autorité de l'État et établir
l'autorité parentale donc deuxième sujet
la question parentale troisième sujet
l'éducation et l'éducation c'est à la
maison mais c'est aussi à l'école et
s'assurer que à l'école et bien les
enseignants et tous les moyens de
pouvoir enseigner convenablement et
aussi une autorité respectée parce qu'on
sait que cette autorité des enseignants
et parfois mise à mal on l'a vu avec des
exemples dans pas uniquement qu'en
banlieue mais de d'enseignants qui
étaient attaqués et remise en cause et
puis ensuite c'est évidemment s'assurer
qu'il y a une plus grande mobilité large
mobilité en s'appuyant sur le réseau
évidemment l'écosystème est important
qu'il soit associatif mais qui soit
aussi des commerçants qui est vivent
dans les quartiers mais pas uniquement
arrêtons de penser et de raisonner quand
on va se clos il y a une vraie mobilité
entre les quartiers entre la ruralité
entre les centres villes arrêtons de
mettre les gens dans des cases comme le
fait la France insoumise actuellement en
opposant
merci Ludovic Mendes on va retrouver
Laurent Marc Angeli le président du
groupe horizon au micro d'Els à mon
Agava oui deux réponses selon vous une
réponse à court terme une réponse à long
terme quels sont-elles la première
réponse est celle de l'ordre de
républicain c'est celle de remettre à la
justice ceux qui sont les fauteurs de
troubles ceux qui pisse ce qui casse et
de les condamner lorsque les faits sont
avérés et la deuxième c'est un débat qui
à mon avis elle doit se faire à tête
reposé mais moi j'ai ma petite idée sur
la question je crois que la question
suivante est bonne c'est fait-on encore
nation sommes-nous en capacité de
pouvoir faire vivre cette république
tous ensemble c'est une question qui
m'aide d'être posée merci beaucoup
Laurent marquant Julie dans quelques
minutes vous poserez des questions à la
première ministre quasiment tous les
présidents de groupe vont faire de même
merci effectivement tous les présidents
de groupe vont interpeller cet
après-midi la première Mini suite aux
émeutes urbaines de ces derniers jours
il y aura beaucoup de questions
évidemment sur les réponses judiciaires
à apporter mais aussi sur le soutien au
maire vous savez que le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses a été vivement attaqué
en tout cas sa famille sa maison à la
voiture bélier ce qui a ému l'ensemble
des mers qui sont reçus actuellement par
le Président de la République à l'Elysée
c'est une réponse politique maintenant
qui est attendue de la part de
l'exécutif du président de la République
et de la première ministre Elsa
mondinguevin on va vous retrouver il y a
beaucoup d'ambiance ici Salle des pas
perdue où on attend la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale comment ça se
passe chez vous côté celle des 4
colonnes et bien écoutez Brigitte les
derniers députés répondent aux questions
on peut voir Sacha Ollier président de
la commission des lois Robin Reda député
Renaissance beaucoup donc de députés de
la majorité qui sont venus en bloc et
bien rappeler peut-être que l'exécutif
compte apporter comme réponse à la crise
en ce moment une réponse de court terme
avec le retour à et de long terme
évidemment puisque les problèmes sont
complexes voilà donc les députés les
derniers députés qui rejoignent
l'hémicycle merci Elsa mandingava et il
est
14h59 pratiquement 15 heures on attend
donc la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale brune Pivet qui va arriver
Salle des pas perdu vous le voyez toutes
les Français qui sont venus voir ces
questions au gouvernement sont présents
ici et attendent avec impatience
l'arrivée dial brun pivelle à garde
républicaine est bien installée bien en
rang les tambours aussi sont prêts pour
donc la présidente de l'Assemblée qui va
présider cette séance de questions au
gouvernement où on va revenir
complètement l'intégralité sur les
violences urbaines et les réponses à
apporter
[Musique]
voilà la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui vient de franchir les
portes de l'émission et qui monte au
perchoirs pour présider cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement
essentiellement consacré aux réponses et
aux conséquences des émeutes urbaines de
ces derniers jours je vous souhaite une
excellente séance et on se retrouve
juste après pour la séance est ouverte